what we're going to do in this video is
use what we know about polynomials and
how to manipulate them and what we've
talked about of whether two polynomials
are equal to each other for all values
of of the variable that they're written
in so whether we're dealing with a
polynomial identity and we're going to
use those skills in order to prove some
properties of relationships between
numbers
so if i were to list out some integers i
could go 0
i could go 1 i could go 2
3 4
5. and if i were to list out the squares
of these if i were to create a sequence
of integer squares well 0 squared would
be 0
1 squared would be 1
2 squared is 4
3 squared is 9. 4 squared is 16
5 squared is 25 and we could of course
keep going in either case but the first
thing i want you to think about before
we even write down a polynomial or try
to construct one is look at this
sequence of integer squares and do you
see any pattern in terms of the
difference between successive terms of
this sequence of integer squares
all right now let's think about this
together
so to go from zero to one
you add one
and you go from one to four
you add
three
to go from
four to nine you add five
to go from nine to sixteen you add seven
it seems like a pattern here as we go to
successive terms of this sequence of
integer squares we're in we're adding
increasing odd numbers so i'm guessing
that if i add 9 here which is the next
odd number i'm going to get to 25 and
that indeed is the case and you could
test that out well what if i add 11
which would be the next odd number what
do i get to i get to 36 which is the
square of 6.
but how can we feel good that this
always is true that this never breaks
down
well one way to do it is to think a
little bit more generally and that's
where our algebra and our knowledge of
polynomials are going to be useful so
let's say we go all the way and we're
just speaking generally now so we have
the number n
and then with the next number after that
is going to be n plus 1.
and then if we think about what the
corresponding terms in the sequence of
integer squares would be well that would
be when we squared when we get to n we
would get n squared and when we get to n
plus 1 we would have n plus 1 squared
and let's see if we could think about
what the difference between these two
things are that's between 25 and 16 is 9
different between 16 and 9 is 7. so
let's think about what the difference
between n plus 1 squared and n squared
is and how do we write that as a
polynomial well it'll just be n plus 1
squared minus
n squared
and now let's see if we can rewrite this
algebraically manipulate this so we can
set up a polynomial identity that
describes this pattern that we just saw
so what i'll do is i'm just going to
expand out n plus 1 squared right over
there so that is going to be n squared
plus 2 n plus 1
and then we have this minus n squared
here so minus n squared
and so
we see that n squared minus n squared
cancels out
and so we can rewrite everything we have
here as n plus 1
squared minus n squared so this is
really the difference between successive
terms in our sequence of integer squares
is going to be equal to
2 n plus 1 for any integer n
well for any integer n what is 2n plus 1
going to be and especially here we're
dealing with the positive integers
well
for any integer n this is going to be an
odd integer if you take any integer you
multiply it by 2
this part is going to be even but then
you add 1 to that you're going to get an
odd integer and you can also see that
this increases by 2 as n increases so
when you go from one odd integer you go
add 2 to the next odd integer you add 2
to the next odd integer which is exactly
what is described there
so this is pretty neat we've just used a
little bit of algebra a little bit of
what we know about polynomial identities
to show that the difference between
successive terms in this sequence of
integer squares right over here is going
to be increasing odd numbers